[Music]
after years of experiments you've
finally created the pets of the future
nano rabbits they're tiny they're fuzzy
and they multiply faster than the eye
can see in your lab there are 36 habitat
cells arranged in an inverted pyramid
with 8 cells in the top row the first
has one rabbit the second has two and so
on with eight rabbits in the last one
the other rows of cells are empty for
now the rabbits are hermaphroditic and
each rabbit in a given cell will breed
once with every rabbit in the horizontal
eat adjacent cells producing exactly one
offspring each time the newborn rabbits
will drop into the cell directly below
the two cells of its parents and within
minutes will mature and reproduce in
turn each cell can hold 10 to the 80th
power nano rabbits that's a one followed
by 80 zeros before they break free and
overrun the world your calculations have
given you a forty six digit number for
the count of rabbits in the bottom cell
plenty of room to spare but just as you
pull the lever to start the experiment
your assistant runs in with terrible
news a rival lab has sabotage your code
so that all the zeros at the end of your
results got cut off that means you don't
actually know if the bottom cell will be
able to hold all the rabbits and the
reproduction is already underway
to make matters worse your devices and
calculators are all malfunctioning so
you only have a few minutes to work it
out by hand
how many trailing zeros should there be
at the end of the count of rabbits in
the bottom habitat and do you need to
pull the emergency shutdown lever
there isn't enough time to calculate the
exact number of rabbits in the final
sell the good news is we don't need to
all we need to figure out is how many
trailing zeros it has but how can we
know how many trailing zeros a number
has without calculating the number
itself what we do know is that we arrive
at the number of rabbits in the bottom
sell through a process of multiplication
literally the number of rabbits in each
cell is the product of the number of
rabbits in each of the two cells above
it and there are only two ways to get
numbers with trailing zeros through
multiplication either multiplying a
number ending in five by any even number
or by multiplying numbers that have
trailing zeros themselves let's
calculate the number of rabbits in the
second row and see what patterns emerge
two of the numbers have trailing zeros
20 rabbits in the fourth cell and 30 in
the fifth cell but there are no numbers
ending in five and since the only way to
get a number ending in five through
multiplication is by starting with a
number ending in five there won't be any
more down the line either that means we
only need to worry about the numbers
that have trailing zeros themselves and
a neat trick to figure out the amount of
trailing zeros in a product is to count
and add the trailing zeros in each of
the factors for example 10 times 100
equals 1,000 so let's take the numbers
in the fourth and fifth cells and
multiply down from there 20 and 30 each
have one zero so the product of both
cells will have two trailing zeros while
the product of either cell in an
adjacent nonzero ending cell will have
only one when we continue all the way
down we end up with 35 zeros in the
bottom cell and if you're not too
stressed about the potential nano rabbit
apocalypse you might notice that
counting the zeros this way forms part
of Pascal's triangle adding those 35
zeros to the forty six digit number we
had before yields an 81 digit number too
big for the habitat to contain you rush
over and pull the emergency switch just
as the 7th
generation of rabbits was about to
mature hair-raising ly close to disaster
continue to challenge your mind with
this riddle playlist
[Music]